우리는 오랫동안 저출산을 한국만의 문제처럼 이야기해왔습니다.
집값이 너무 비싸고 사교육비가 부담되고 일자리가 불안해서
젊은 세대가 결혼과 출산을 미룬다고 말해왔죠.
맞는 말입니다.
그런데 최근 세계 출산율 그래프를 보면
이 설명만으로는 풀리지 않는 장면들이 나옵니다.
한때 멕시코는 미국보다 훨씬 아이를 많이 낳는 나라로 여겨졌습니다.
가족 중심 문화가 강하고 젊은 인구가 많고
출산율도 높은 나라라는 이미지가 있었죠.
그런데 지금은 멕시코의 출산율이 미국보다 낮아졌습니다.
이건 멕시코 하나의 변화가 아닙니다.
우리가 알고 있던 상식이 뒤집히고 있다는 신호입니다.
동아시아, 북유럽, 라틴 아메리카, 중동과 북아프리카까지
출산율은 같은 방향으로 내려가고 있습니다.
문화도 다르고 종교도 다르고
경제 수준도 다른 나라들에서 비슷한 변화가 나타나는 겁니다.
그래서 우리는 질문을 한번 바꿔보겠습니다.
왜 한국만 아이를 안 낳을까가 아니라
왜 전 세계가
거의 동시에 아이를 덜 낳기 시작했을까요?
여기서 잠깐 오늘 영상의 공식 스폰서
노드VPN을 소개해드리겠습니다.
최근 한국 인터넷 환경을 보면
이제 온라인 접속이라는 게 예전처럼 단순하지 않습니다.
지난 5월 11일 저작권 침해 사이트에 대한
정부의 긴급 차단 제도가 시행되면서
특정 사이트들의 접근이 빠르게 제한되고 있고
몇몇 커뮤니티에서는
검열 및 프라이버시 침해에 대한 우려를 보이고 있습니다.
물론 VPN으로 불법 콘텐츠를 보자는 이야기가
아니냐, 아니죠.
핵심은 합법적인 인터넷 이용 안에서도
내 접속 기록과 개인 정보를 스스로 보호해야 하는
시대가 됐다는 겁니다.
노드VPN은 사용자의 온라인 활동 기록을 남기지 않는
노루그 정책을 내세우고 있고
바이러스 및 위협 방지 프로 기능을 통해
사기 사이트, 악성 다운로드, 추적기 같은
위험 요소를 줄이는데 도움을 줍니다.
여기에 다크웹 모니터링,
킬 스위치 같은 기능도 제공해서
단순히 IP만 바꿔주는 VPN이라기보다 전반적인 온라인 모니터링을 제공하고 있습니다.
여기에 다크웹 모니터링, 킬 스위치 같은 기능을 제공하고 있습니다.
일단 무엇보다 설정이 복잡하지 않습니다.
처음 VPN을 써보는 분들도 클릭 한 번이면
가장 빠른 서버에 연결되고
한 계정으로 최대 10대까지 함께 쓸 수 있어서
가족 단위로 쓰기에도 좋습니다.
더보기란과 고정 댓글에 있는 지식부 장관 전용 링크
또는 쿠폰코드 MOK를 통해 들어가시면
2년 플랜 기준 최대 할인과 4개월 추가 혜택이 제공됩니다.
그리고 30일 환불 보장도 가능합니다.
평소 VPN이나 온라인 보안 서비스가 필요하셨던 분들은
직접 비교해 보셔도 좋을 것 같습니다.
자, 이제 다시 출산율 이야기로 돌아와 보겠습니다.
그래서 오늘 우리가 봐야 할 숫자는 출산율 하나가 아닙니다.
바로 커플율입니다.
지금 사람들은 아이를 덜 낳기 전에
먼저 서로 덜 만나고 있습니다.
우리는 보통 저출산을 돈 문제로 설명합니다.
집값이 너무 비싸다.
육아비가 너무 부담된다.
교육비가 너무 많이 든다.
미래가 불안합니다.
불안하니까 결혼도 출산도 미룬다.
하지만 이제 이 설명만으로는 부족합니다.
만약 저출산이 단순히 집값과 소득의 문제라면
비슷한 경제 구조를 가진 나라들에서만
비슷한 현상이 나타나야 합니다.
그런데 지금은 그렇지 않습니다.
가족주의가 강했던 나라에서도
과거 출산율이 높았던 나라에서도
중소득 국가에서도 출산율은 빠르게 떨어지고 있습니다.
25세에서 34세 사이 젊은 성인 중 결혼을 했거나
동거 중인 사람들의 비율이
여러 지역에서 내려가고 있습니다.
동아시아만 그런 것이 아닙니다.
라틴아메리카도, 서구권도, 중동과 북아프리카도
비슷한 흐름을 보입니다.
우리는 출산율을 말할 때
보통 아이가 태어나는 순간만 떠올립니다.
병원, 분만실, 출생아수, 합계출산율 같은 숫자입니다.
하지만 아이가 태어나기 전에는 훨씬 긴 과정이 있습니다.
누군가를 만나야 하고, 관계를 지속해야 하고,
함께 살 수 있어야 하고, 미래를 같이 상상할 수 있어야 합니다.
그런데 지금 그 과정이 약해지고 있습니다.
해당 그래프의 흐름을 보면
커플이 되는 비율과 출산율이 함께 내려갑니다.
물론 이것만으로 커플 감소가 저출산의 전부라고 말할 수는 없습니다.
하지만 방향은 분명합니다.
아이를 낳는 사람이 줄어드는 이유는
한 가정이 아이를 한 명 덜 낳기 때문만이 아닙니다.
아이 가족을 시작하는 사람의 수가 줄고 있기 때문입니다.
이 그래프는 관점을 더 바꿔줍니다.
이미 엄마가 된 여성들이 낳는 아이의 수는
어느 정도 안정된 흐름을 보입니다.
그런데 아이를 가진 여성의 비율은
다시 말해서 엄마가 되는 여성의 비율은 내려갑니다.
문제는 단순히 둘째를 안 낳는 것이 아닙니다.
첫째까지 가는 길 자체가 막히고 있다는 겁니다.
그래서 요즘 사람들은 그냥 아이를 원치 않는다.
젊은 세대가 이기적이라 아이를 안 낳는다는 말은
너무 흔한 사회적 통념에 가깝습니다.
한국, 영국, 핀란드, 프랑스의 흐름을 보면
사람들이 이상적으로 생각하는 아이의 수와
실제 아이 수 사이의 간격이 벌어지고 있습니다.
많은 사람들은
여전히 아이를 원합니다.
다만 원하는 만큼의 가족을 만들지 못하는 겁니다.
원하는 삶과 실제 가능한 삶 사이의
간격이 커지고 있다는 의미겠죠.
그렇다면 집값은 얼마나 중요한가?
당연히 중요합니다.
집은 단순히 부동산이 아닙니다.
결혼과 동거, 출산의 물리적 기반입니다.
함께 살 공간이 없으면
관계는 미래로 나아가기 어렵겠죠.
월세와 대출 부담이 크면 아이를 계획하기 어렵습니다.
하지만 집값만큼의 가족을 만들지 못하는 것입니다.
집값만으로는 최근의 급격한 하락 전체를 설명하기 어렵다는 겁니다.
주거 문제는 분명 큰 원인입니다.
그러나 전 세계 여러 문화권에서 비슷한 시기에
출산율과 관계율이 함께 떨어지는 현상을
모두 설명하기에는 부족합니다.
그래서 또 하나의 변수를 봐야 합니다.
바로 스마트폰입니다.
스마트폰이 출산율을 떨어뜨렸다고 단정할 수는 없습니다.
하지만 스마트폰은 사람들의 시간을 바꿨습니다.
만나는 방식을 바꿨고 외로움을 견디는 방식도 바꿨습니다.
예전에는 심심하면 밖으로 나가서 친구를 만나고
모임에 나가고 우연히 누군가를 마주쳤습니다.
지금은 혼자 있어도 심심하지 않습니다.
휴대폰 안에 영상, 게임, SNS, 끝없는 콘텐츠가 있습니다.
사람들은 연결되어 있는 것처럼 보이지만
실제로는 덜 만날 수 있습니다.
미국, 영국, 유럽, 한국의 흐름을 보면
젊은 사람들이 다른 사람들과 어울리는 시간이 줄어드는 모습이 나타납니다.
한국의 경우에도 15세에서 29세 사이
청년들이 대면으로 사회화하는 시간이 줄어듭니다.
이 장면은 저출산 논의에서 자주 빠집니다.
출산은 생물학적 사건입니다.
하지만 그 이전에는 사회적 사건입니다.
사람이 사람을 만나야 출산이 가능합니다.
사람이 사람을 신뢰해야 가족을 상상할 수 있습니다.
그런데 젊은 세대가 서로 만나는 시간 자체가 줄어든다면
출산율은 영향을 받을 수밖에 없습니다.
여기서 문제는 단지 외로움이 아닙니다.
관계의 난이도도 올라갔습니다.
여기에 계층과
젠더 변화도 겹칩니다.
영국과 미국에서는 장기적 관계의 감소가
특히 대학 학위가 없는 사람들에게서 더 크게 나타납니다.
고용이 불안정하고 소득 전망이 약할수록
누군가와 함께 미래를 꾸릴 수 있다는 감각도 약해집니다.
결혼은 감정의 문제이기도 하지만 동시에 생활의 문제입니다.
젊은 여성의 경제적 위치는 올라가고 있습니다.
이 변화 자체는 긍정적인 변화죠.
하지만 과거의 결혼 모델은 그 변화를 따라가지 못했습니다.
과거의 결혼 모델은 남성이 더 많이 벌고
여성이 돌봄을 더 많이 담당하는 구조에 기대고 있었습니다.
그런데 여성의 경제적 위치는 빠르게 올라가는데
가사와 돌봄, 결혼에 대한 기대는 그 속도를 따라가지 못합니다.
여성은 더 이상 불평등한 관계를 감수할 이유가 줄었습니다.
남성은 예전처럼 가장 역할을 맡을 경제적 기반을 갖기 어려워졌습니다.
그 사이에서 관계는 더 늦어지고 더 신중해지고
때로는 아예 시작되지 않습니다.
여기에 남녀의 정치적, 문화적 거리까지 벌어지면
관계는 더 늦어집니다.
여기까지 보면 저출산의 그림이 조금 달라집니다.
우리는 보통 출산율을 숫자로 봅니다.
하지만 그 숫자 아래에는 더 복잡한 변화가 있습니다.
사람들은 덜 만납니다. 덜 사귑니다. 덜 함께 삽니다. 덜 결혼합니다.
그리고 그 결과 아이도 덜 태어납니다.
그러니까 저출산은 단순히 출산의 문제가 아닙니다.
관계의 문제입니다.
그래서 출산율 정책도 달라져야 합니다.
정부는 오랫동안 출산율 정책도 달라져야 합니다. 정부는 오랫동안 출산율 정책도 달라져야 합니다.
출산율을 올리기 위해 현금 지원, 세금 혜택, 육아 수당, 보육 정책을 이야기해 왔습니다.
이 정책들도 필요하죠.
아이를 키우는 비용을 낮추는 일은 분명 중요하니까요.
하지만 그것만으로는 충분하지 않습니다.
사람들이 아이를 낳기 전에 먼저 해야 하는 일이 있습니다.
만나야 합니다.
관계를 유지해야 하고 함께 살 공간을 마련해야 합니다.
서로의 미래를 믿을 수 있어야 합니다.
그 조건이 무너지면 아무리 출산 장려금을 늘려도
출산율은 쉽게 떨어집니다.
저출산의 출발점은 분만실이 아닙니다.
사람들이 처음 서로를 만나는 자리입니다.
그리고 마지막으로
이번 영상 후원을 해주신 NODVPN
전용 링크 남겨두겠습니다.
오늘도 영상 시청해 주셔서 감사합니다.